what about in terms of shifting costs
and making workers you know have to
watch the cost of themselves so this is
this is an interesting one so this is
market forces coming to bear right why
is it that we don't know how much it
costs for knee surgery why is it that
you don't know when you go to the
emergency room how much it actually
costs you right and you think about that
situation and that's just something that
has happened over the years after World
War two of course and the incentives for
employers to provide medical care for
their employees that decision alone and
the incentives associated to that has
really caused particularly here in the
United States our addiction to having
somebody else play for our health so who
cares what it costs in a sense we've
we've essentially surrendered it and
said somebody else gets to pay for it I
don't have to worry about it what's
happened now and what employers are
doing across the board is offering all
sorts of different levels of health care
spent high-deductible plans lower
deductible plans and all of a sudden
people are going will hold on a second
I've got to pay for that yeah and guess
what it changes their behavior it
changed my behavior you know you choose
what am I going to go to an urgent care
and get a quick take on this prom i'm
going to go to the emergency room and
those costs you know the difference is
right an emergency room can cost you as
high as a thousand dollars a visit and
in an urgent care will cost you forty
five dollars a visit right and you
probably will get the same sort of
diagnosis of it that's not too serious
and i think you're not that sick that
you're going to decide to go if you've
got you know brain hemorrhage you go to
the urgent care center those kind of
decisions the consumerism of health care
the transparency of pricing has to be
put into place
us to actually be able to really work on
this health care juggernaut so that
decision of actually offering different
types of programs was something that was
pretty well thought out and now
employees in particular really do look
and care about what sort of medical
decisions they're making